vous savez le seul avantage avec les
écho terroristes de la trompe de Total
énergie c'est qu'il nous donne
l'embarras du choix en matière de
question tant les comptes à rendre sont
nombreux aussi je pourrais vous
interroger monsieur pouyanet sur vos
aventures néocoloniales sur le continent
africain votre méga projet gazier et à
coop en Ouganda par exemple dont on
estime si on prend en compte le
transport le raffinage et la combustion
du pétrole pour les par les pays
consommateurs qu'il produirait
l'équivalent de 25 fois les émissions
annuelles de l'Ouganda et de la Tanzanie
réunie là-bas le cauchemar est nommé
total à coup d'accaparent de terre
entraînant la violation des droits de
près de 100 000 personnes comme l'ont
condamné récemment nos collègues du
Parlement européen dans une résolution
mais à combien évaluez-vous la vie d'une
famille vous allez pour ce projet
icoop exproprier
une famille en Tanzanie le prix de
l'expropriation c'est en moyenne
1160 dollars est-ce que quelqu'un pense
ici qu'avec 1160 dollars on peut ensuite
faire vivre sa famille quand on sait
qu'en plus le prix des terrains augmente
au fur et à mesure que le projet se
développe moi j'en ai un peu assez
d'entendre qu'il y a 100000 personnes ou
100000 foyers monsieur fort qui sont
déplacés alors je vais vous donner les
chiffres réels le nombre de foyers qui
sont concernés par la nécessité de les
reloger et nous reconstruisons des
maisons et de 769 foyers 769 voyez vous
pouvez dire c'est beaucoup oui
769 pas 100000 foyers après il y a des
terres agricoles je continue il y a des
terres agricoles des gens qui possèdent
des terres que nous devons indemniser
que nous l'indemnisons pas du tout à
1000 dollars par hectare comme je l'ai
entendu en Ouganda mais plus cher que ça
à un prix relativement élevé
et le nombre de paires de terre
agricoles de personnes concernées par
des terres agricoles que nous devons
effectivement compenser et de 19000
je croyais que dans un état de droit le
principe du contradictoire était
fondamental et qu'avant d'accuser
quelqu'un d'accuser à une organisation
sur un sujet qui relève de la
souveraineté au passage de l'Ouganda et
de l'antarzanie on pouvait demander aux
personnes de venir s'expliquer personne
ne nous a jamais demandé on nous a
demandé après que la résolution était
votée devenue on m'a demandé de venir
pour 8 minutes nous expliquer sur un
sujet qui mérite bien évidemment plus de
temps voilà ce qui s'est passé au
Parlement européen